if we think of ourselves as in the eye
of the storm of an another Extinction
the the natural question to ask here is
you have all all of nature and then you
have this new human creation that is
currently being termed artificial
intelligence
how does your work play with the
possibility of of a future super
intelligent ecosystem and AGI that
either joins or supersedes humans yeah
so I'm glad you asked this question
and I hope for terrified both I'm
hopeful and terrified I did watch your
interview with Ellie ezrautkovski and I
loved it because you were scared or
because you were excited or because
there's first of all I was both I was
I totally scared
shamed cited and totally also inspired
because he's just such an incredible
thinker and and I can agree or disagree
with what he says but I just found his
way of thinking about AGI and and The
Perils of humanity as a result there's
an inevitability to what he's saying his
advice to young people is that prepare
for a short life yeah he thinks
it's very
almost
simple it's almost common sense that AGI
would get rid of humans that he can't
imagine a trajectory
eventually that leads to a place that
doesn't have AGI kill all humans there's
just too many trajectories where a super
intelligence system gets rid of humans
and in the near term and so yeah the the
that Clarity of thinking is very uh
sobering to me
it's maybe it is to you as well it's
super inspiring because I think he's
wrong but it's like you you almost want
to prove them wrong
it's like no we humans are clever Bunch
we're gonna find a way it is a bit like
jumping into super cold water it's sort
of a kind of a fist in your face it
wakes you up and I like these moments so
much
um and and he was able to bring that
moment to life even though I think
a mother can never
think that way ever
um and and it's a little bit like that
that notion of I I love her more than
Evolution requires on your question
about AGI in nature look I think we've
been through a lot in terms of to to get
here we sort of moved from data right
the ability to collect information to
knowledge the ability to use this
information for utility from knowledge
to intelligence and what is intelligence
is the ability to problem solve and
adapt and translate so that sort of from
from data to information to knowledge I
think the next Frontier is wisdom
um and what is wisdom wisdom is the
ability to have or find Insight
um about
um the world and from wisdom to
spiritual awareness which is sort of
transcends wisdom and is able and to
chart the world into new territory but I
think what is interesting about AGI is
that it is sort of almost like a
self-recursive thing right because it's
like a washing machine of like a third
derivative Wikipedia it uses kind of
like language to create language to
create language to create language it
feels like novelty is being constantly
created I don't I don't it doesn't feel
like it's regurgitating and that's so
fascinating because you know these are
not the stochastic parrots this is sort
of a new form of emergence perhaps of uh
of of novelty as you say that exists by
virtue of using old things to create new
things
um
um but it's not as if the AGI has
self-awareness right it's not as if it
has maybe maybe maybe maybe it maybe it
has but as far as I can tell it's not as
if AGI has approached Consciousness or
sentience just yet it it it's it's
probably getting there but the language
appears to present itself as if as if
there is sentience there but it doesn't
but I think that's the problem at the
point where this AGI sounds like me and
speaks like me and behaves like me and
feels like me and breathes like me and
my daughter knows the AGI to be me is
sort of the end of it and the end of
everything right it's the end of human
agency
but what is the end of human agency to
humans I think is the beginning of
agency to Nature because if you take all
of this agency if you take all of these
language models that can summarize all
of human civilization and Consciousness
and then upload that to Nature and have
nature now deal with that World Of
Consciousness that it never had access
to
so maybe through eliezel's lands the
short-lived human becomes sort of a very
long-lived human like sentient weeping
willow maybe maybe that's the end and
the beginning and and and and maybe
um on the more optimistic side uh for us
humans
um it's a different form of existence uh
where everything we create and
everything we consume and everything we
process is all
made up of six uh you know six elements
and that's it and there's only those six
elements and not 118 elements and
um and and it's all the stuff of biology
plus some you know fair amount of bits
bits genes and atoms well I think the
idea a lot of Beethoven a lot of
Beethoven I think the idea of connecting
AGI to Nature through your work is
really fascinating
sort of uh
unlocking this incredible Machinery of
intelligence that is Agi
and connecting it to the incredible
Machinery of wisdom that is nature has
evolved through billions of years oh
pretty crazy intense Evolution exactly
and unlike sort of again I'm going back
to
directed Evolution unlike
um this sort of high throughput Brute
Force approach if there is a way to
utilize this Synergy for
diversity and diversification
like
like yeah how like what happens if you
ask a chat GPT question but it takes 10
000 years to answer that question like
what does that look like right when you
like completely switch the time scale
um and you can afford the time to answer
the question
and I again I I don't know but but that
world to me is possibly amazing